Logging, monitoring and observability.
This is a huge topic and each portion
itself. If we talk about logging or if
we talk about monitoring and if we talk
about observability, they themselves are
deserving enough to get their own
discussion, get their own video. But
this is also one of those topics where
not everything is predecided. Uh there
are no rules. It's more of a spectrum.
These are obviously practices logging,
monitoring and observability. I will get
to why do we need this and what are
these exactly but these are practices
which most companies most individuals
startups they implement in a spectrum.
We can never say that our product our
company follows all the good logging
monitoring and observability practices.
There is no such thing as that. So given
that we just wanted to put that
information out there so that we don't
uh feel intimidated uh later on when we
see all these different different
keywords practices products and tools
that get used all over the industry. Now
what is what are these terms? What is
logging? What is monitoring and what is
observability? uh as I said this since
this is a huge topic I don't want to
spend hours discussing these uh even
though we can spend hours uh these
topics are huge but we'll keep this to
limited since uh these are more of a
practices than theory I'll also show
more code in this video even though from
the start of this series I have kept
this as a rule that we won't look at
code but this is one of those videos
where if you don't look at code this
does not really make any sense All these
practices they are pretty closely
related to code, how we implement them,
how we follow these practices. That's
why we'll look at code how these work in
a real application. Now coming back to
why do we need this? Now since we know
that uh these days in modern uh internet
all our backend applications, all our
fullstack applications they run in a
distributed environment and they run in
different different servers. They run in
different different regions and our
users are spread across the whole world.
Given these scenarios, we need
practices, we need tools and we need
methodologies so that we can keep track
of what's happening in all our services,
in all our infrastructure tools and
everything. And what do I mean by keep
track? There are a couple of uh
parameters we can keep track of. There
are a lot of parameters but we can boil
them down to some of the important ones.
Now logging basically means we record
record. So it's kind of a record all the
events that are happening in our
application. Again these practices login
monitoring and observability these also
apply for front-end applications your
web applications but we will keep the
discussion limited to backend
applications. As I was saying, logging
is basically recording all the important
events, all the suspicious events, all
the security related events. Pretty much
every important event that happens in
our application, in our back end
application, we want to record that
event with some metadata. Metadata
basically means what was the user ID
which triggered this particular request
and what was the latency of this request
and what particular method what
particular function was triggered for
this request and all these different
different media that will come in handy
when we are actually trying to
understand our system. So the first
thing the first component of this whole
methodology is logging which is
basically recording all the events from
the whole life cycle of requests and our
application execution. The second thing
is monitoring. Monitoring basically is
exactly the same as the way it sounds.
We want some way of keeping track. We
cannot simplify it more than that. We
want to monitor the state of all our
applications, our backend application
and different components of our backend
application. The server's CPU, the
server's uh memory, how many requests
the server is processing per second at
this particular time and what is the
state of our database connections, how
many database connections are open
because we are using database pooling
etc. Monitoring basically means having
realtime data about our system. Not
exactly real time but a few minutes
differing because one thing about
logging monitoring and observability all
these practices these data even though
there are tools where we can monitor in
real time with a few milliseconds few
seconds deferring but usually without
traditional tools without traditional
practices there is some kind of delay
because uh we don't want to overwhelm
our whole logging monitoring and
observability systems with constant data
with every millisecond with every
second. So there is some kind of delay
around 10 second or 15 seconds.
Monitoring basically means that having
real time data real time we mean 10 15
seconds of delay. Having realtime data
about the state of our system that's all
about monitoring and the next is
observability. Now observability is in
itself includes a lot of other practices
and if you go by uh theoretical terms
observability has uh three pillars. We
like to call them as pillars because a
system a backend system is can only be
called observable if all these three
practices if all these three components
are in place. So those are one is
basically logs. second metrics and third
is traces. Now logs we already know logs
are basically record of all the
important event that is happening across
our uh request life cycle our
application startup application ending
the whole phase metrics metrics is
something which closely relates to
monitoring I'll come back to this part a
little later and same way traces traces
you can imagine traces as transactions a
trace basically means that we want some
way of tracking at what point a request
originated from one system. It can be a
front- end system. It can be a load
balancer or it can be starting from your
backend application. From that point on,
what are all the components? Uh let's
say if you have a handler layer, you
have a service layer, you have a
validation layer, you have a repository
layer and then the database layer. Using
traces we can track uh when a request
originated where it originated from and
we can track all these components that
it touched through while our backend
application is was executing this
particular request. A trace is basically
a transaction including all the
different components that it involves.
Basically we'll come back to more formal
definitions and more explanations a
little later on but just for the
starting part I gave a very high level
introduction to logging monitoring and
observability on a very high level now
this whole practice of observability is
uh pretty modern a few years it's only
been a few years using a traditional
monitoring let's say decade back the
primary form of preventing errors or
catching errors or any kind of error
handling on an infrastructure level was
mostly dependent on monitoring
practices. But the problem with that is
monitoring only tells you uh that there
is a problem. We have different
different tools. We have different
different workflows to set up alerts
using graphana. We'll come back to what
are the tools we have available in our
arsenal. But using all these tools,
using all these monitoring
methodologies, we can know we'll know
that there are issues in our application
and we'll get alerts and everything. But
that's pretty much it. Uh we cannot
really do anything about it. We'll just
get informed that there is something
wrong with your application. And with
this whole new movement of
observability, it will inform you that
there is something wrong with your
application. But it will also tell you
exactly what is wrong with your
application given that you have followed
all the observability practices. You
have implemented logs, you have
implemented metrics and you have
implemented traces. But that is the
oneline definition and explanation of
observability. Now let's uh drill down
on different different components. The
logging, monitoring and observability
part. So the first one was logging and
as I said logging is the practice of
recording all the important events in
our whole application life cycle.
Examples like let's say a user logs in
or we execute a database query or
something fails and we log that error
with time stamp with the user ID with
the database query and everything all
the context that we need to debug that
error. You can think of logs as kind of
a journal or a diary your backend
application maintains so that when the
time comes we will know what happened
when happened and exactly why it
similarly monitoring monitoring as I
said it's uh getting real time data
getting basically continuously checking
the health and the performance of your
system and tracking the patterns over
time and giving an aggregation data that
uh these this was the performance this
was the behavior of your application
over time including the current time
right that is all about monitoring and
the third one is observability we can
call uh a system as observable if we can
determine the internal state of the
application by looking at different
different parameters by looking at the
external outputs that's when we call
that a system is observable. Now, how do
all these three things work together?
They work together because each of them
produce one concrete parameter that is
useful when we are debugging our system,
when we want to understand our system.
For example, using logs, we will know
that what happened, what exactly
happened. Using monitoring, we'll know
about metrics. We'll talk more about
what exactly this term metrics mean. But
using metrics we'll know about patterns
and trends. Now the third one using
observability we'll find traces. Traces
is linked with observability. Traces as
I said they are transactions and using
these we can find out the interaction of
different components component
interactions. So this is uh if you have
already worked in a production system
which implements proper logging
monitoring and observability this is how
it works. Let's say we have uh set up
some alert parameters that if our error
rate goes beyond 80%. Something like
this then we'll get an message in Slack
that something is wrong with your API
service. You should look into that. And
from there we'll go to metrics. In
metrics we'll see that metric is
basically different different parameters
different different realtime parameters
and historical parameters that we can
track about our system. Some of the
examples are how many requests we have
processed. How many requests have failed
and failed basically means any request
which gave the status code is more than
200. We can consider that as failed
request. Similarly, if let's say your
application deals with to-do list, then
how many to-dos we have created and how
many of them failed. All these things,
all these concrete numbers, when you're
talking about numbers over either
historical data or the current numbers
in the last 30 minutes, in the last 1
hour, these things are called metrics
and we can preddecide these when we are
configuring our whole logging monitoring
and observable system. We can configure
these things that these are the metrics
that we care about both in our code and
in our logging monitoring and
observability whatever tool that we are
using. So if you get an alert because
your error rate just went above 80%. We
get an error in slack using some kind of
web hook then from there you'll look at
the metrics and in the metrics you'll
see that you are getting more errors is
your error rate is more than 80%. From
there you will jump into usually in
systems uh whatever system that you are
using either we have open source tools
like graphana prometheus and jagger for
traces and same way we have other tools
like new relic which is something that
we will see in this video which is kind
of a one-stop solution if you don't want
to go to the opensource route
configuring all the opensource
applications etc. So you if you're using
something like Grafana which is an open
source tool or New Relic dashboard is a
proprietary software from the metrics we
can immediately find the logs let's say
it says from the metric it says that
your error rate is more than 80%. And it
will also show you that these are the
logs related to that metric. Basically
all the failed logs and from the logs
you can directly jump into traces. Let's
say you saw a log where it says 500
something and when you click on this
it'll also show you traces. Basically
for this log the request started at this
function and then it traveled to this
function then it traveled to this
function and it failed at this
particular point. And using this whole
workflow you can find out exactly where
things went wrong and you can instantly
debug it. And that is the whole benefit
of implementing this whole logging,
monitoring and observability in your
backend systems. Next up, we'll talk a
little more about different different
concepts in logging concepts in
monitoring and different concepts in
observability. But before that, let me
tell you a little bit about the sponsor
of this video is Seala. Seala is a
platform as a service provider. If you
have used services like Netlifi, Versel,
Heroku, then there's an alternative to
that. In Savala, you can deploy full
stack applications and you can also
deploy your databases. You can also
deploy custom applications. Let's say we
were talking about observability a while
back. So if you want to deploy Graphfana
or Prometheus and Jagger and open
telemetry collectors then you can deploy
all those applications by dockerizing
them and you can connect all these
applications to your back end using
their internal network if you deploy
them in the same region. After deploying
the first time, you can connect your
GitHub repository and the next time you
push something to whatever your main
branch is, it gets autodeployed using a
GitHub bot. Savala uses Kubernetes under
the hood uh using GCP with their premium
network tier to completely abstract away
all the complexity that you have to deal
with if you had to do all these
deployments manually using AWS or any
kind of cloud providers. You never have
to touch any kind of YAML files or
manage any kind of containers. The
platform supports three kind of build
options. We have Nyx packs which by
default supports more than 20 languages
with better resource efficiency than
traditional build packs. It also
supports build packs for compatibility
with Heroku. If your infrastructure is
already in Heroku, then it also supports
build packs so that your migration is as
smooth as possible. And if you want to
go the custom way, it also supports
deploying your applications to docker
file and giving yourself the complete
control about how you want to configure
and how you want to deploy your
applications. It also provides this very
useful feature if you are working in a
team which is preview deployments. If
you have used versel before, they also
offer the similar kind of feature. And
preview deployments basically means if
someone one of the team members raise a
PR then you will instantly get a domain
and you can click on the domain and you
can actually use your application with
the all the changes from the new PR and
then you can decide whether to merge the
PR or to request for more changes and
this comes in very handy if you are
working in a team and also if you are a
oneperson team you can quickly become
more productive with this kind workflow.
All your applications run on Google's
infrastructure with Cloudflare's edge
network. Your static assets get cached
across 260 plus points of presence using
the Cloudflare's edge network. The
internal communication between services
are free and the bandwidth costs is 33%
less than Versel at just 0.10
per GB. So if that sounds interesting to
you, if that sounds more cost effective
to you, then you can get started with
Savala by signing up with the below link
you'll find in the description and
you'll get $50 worth of credit free to
try it out and decide for yourself if it
makes sense or not. You'll stop spending
hours fighting deployment and you'll
actually start shipping features. Now
coming back to our discussion logging.
Let's talk a little bit about logging.
What are the things that you have to
keep in mind? Again this is very
informal talk. We are not going to go
with the definitions and all the
different tools and components that you
have to know about. I'll keep it
practical. Whatever you have to know to
get started and to get to far enough so
that you can figure things out for
yourself. And the first thing when we
are talking about logging is levels.
Logging levels this is something that
you will see a lot in production systems
when we are logging a particular event
usually if uh your library supports that
which it should then we assign a
particular level to that log and these
levels are usually let's say something
like debug or info or warn let's say
error or fat. These are the most common
ones. At debug, we use the log level
debug when we are in development and we
are trying to basically debug something.
We are trying to troubleshoot something
and we need as much details about the
behavior of the systems as possible.
These debug logs can be a bit
overwhelming. So that's why we only care
about debug logs uh in development. We
usually disable it in production. Then
comes the info logs. Uh these are
general application operations. The
business events let's say you have a
to-do application then if a to-do gets
created then we use log.info to log that
event general information or successful
operations any kind of successful
operation we can use the info level.
Same way warning uh these are events uh
which are in between info and error.
This is not a successful operation and
this is also not critical enough that we
want to add it as an error. For example,
if for a user the authentication fails
then we just log that event as a warning
that this user has typed a wrong
password but this is not an error. This
is not our fault. Right? So in those
cases we can use the warn level. Same
way for errors. Any kind of errors you
can imagine the validation errors or if
your database query fails all kinds of
errors we log it as errors. This is the
most common one. One of the reasons we
use logging in the first place. Then
comes the fatal. The fatal is uh pretty
serious. Once you log something with the
level fatal, your application mostly
stops and it restarts depending on your
infrastructure configurations. But fatal
basically means that this is a very
serious bug, a very serious issue and
your application is shutting down. And
that's all about levels. And we'll go
through the code to get more intuition
about log levels and everything. But
let's just get through the theory part
first and we'll see what it looks like.
Then comes structured versus
unstructured logs. We usually log in two
different kinds of ways. The first kind
is console logs. When you are in your
development environment, when you are
running your back end in your local,
then we want to log whatever logs that
we are recording throughout our
application running. We want to log
those in our console. Wherever you are
running in your VS code console, in your
terminal, whatever console, we want to
log them. And we want to log them in a
readable way in a more attractive way
because it's easier to understand. It's
easier to spot issues and it's easier to
fix them. So during development we want
to keep the logs readable. We want to
keep the logs attractive with colors and
all. And we want to make it human
readable in the sense it should be plain
text. The same way structural logging.
Structural logging basically means JSON
is the most popular format for
structural logging. Instead of printing
human readable text what we do we print
the error in JSON format and it will
have all the parameters that what is the
status of the error what is the message
of the error and all these things but if
we do this in development environment uh
it's hard to read and it's easy to miss
issues miss errors in our system that's
why we use JSON logging or structured
logging in our production systems
because in our production system. All
these logs are either depending on your
configuration are either getting parsed
through some kind of log management
application. Let's say we have ELK stack
or if you are using the open-source
tools like Loki, Promptale, Graphana,
the whole graphana stack. All these logs
are getting parsed. If they are in text
format, then all these tools they'll
have a hard time parsing it and they'll
face a lot of errors. which is not
efficient enough to parse a line of text
and extract valuable parameters like the
user ID, the request ID and things like
that. That's why in production system we
log in JSON format so that it's easy to
parse and it's easy to extract all the
valuable information. That's all about
structured and unstructured logging. In
development we use unstructured logging
to make it userfriendly to make it easy
to spot errors in development
environment. In production, we log in
JSON format so that it's easier for our
tools, the log management tools to parse
our logs and give us the valuable
insights. Since we are mostly talking
about practices, I think it is better to
to show how they actually work instead
of just talking in theory. Even though
that's the whole point of this series,
we'll make an exception for this video
so that we have an easier understanding
about this all complicated logging,
monitoring and observability. This is
the code of a to-do application and the
back end is written in Go and this
application tries to follow all the
practices the logging monitoring and
observability and we are using a tool
called New Relic. If we look up new
relic, this is a complete solution for
logging, monitoring and observability
needs of different different systems. We
also have tools called graphana which is
actually the front end part the
dashboard part and the back end is
usually dealt with Prometheus which
actually builds all these metrics and
all. These are the tools that's used in
most of the enterprises. the graphana
stack that we like to call with
Prometheus, Graphfana, Promptale and
Jagger for traces. But if you want a
simple integration, a simple workflow,
then something like New Relic makes more
sense. If you don't have the team size,
if you don't have the resources to
maintain all these different open-source
tools, then you can definitely go for
something like New Relic. And that's
exactly what I have done in for this
application. Configuring all these
logging, monitoring and observability is
pretty complicated. If you don't have
the experience, if you don't have the
time for it, then going with a
proprietary solution makes more sense.
So with that context, let me show how we
have implemented logging monitoring and
observability in this system. How they
actually work and with this we'll
understand how different different parts
of logging monitoring and observability
work. So the first part if we see so
another thing is uh please don't try to
understand the code don't try to uh
memorize the code and don't get
overwhelmed the whole point of this
video is just to show how the operations
work how the practices work in the
logging monitoring and observability
topic not the code but we are just using
the code. This is the file which creates
a new logger before our application
starts and it has a couple of
configurations. The first thing that I
want to show because we just talked
about is different different levels of
logging. We have a function called get
log level which basically checks if we
are in development mode which means that
we are running in our local or if we are
in production mode which means that we
have deployed our application it's
running in our infrastructure depending
on that it either returns an info level
or a debug level because in local we
want more logs for debugging purpose and
in production we want just the
information related logs And using this
function we can filter out we can
configure that. The second thing is the
structured versus unstructured logging
thing. By default we have set the
logging format as console because it is
a development environment. But let's say
we change it to JSON. And here instead
of local we make it to now if we start
the server task. As you can see that we
are getting all the logs in JSON format
and it's great for production
environments but it's not very readable.
If we go ahead and change it back to the
development setup from env. This is what
the development blogs look like as this
is definitely more readable in our local
environment. We can clearly see that the
first log is about connecting to
database. The second one started the
background job server and the third one
is starting the server right as compared
to the earlier uh JSON format which is
not very easy to understand but it's
definitely easy to parse for other
tools. Now the second thing that we
talked about was monitoring and for that
to work what we have done if we go to
the router we have set up this
middleware called uh Newelic middleware.
If we go inside that is basically
initializing a new middleware with
wrapping our whole app. What happens
exactly with this middleware is if we
look at the source code every time a new
request comes it does something the it
instruments the whole request. Now if
you are talking about observability two
terms you'll hear very frequently. One
is instrumentation. The second one is
open telemetry. Instrumentation is
basically the practice of actually
measuring different different attributes
of your function which is closely
related to when we call a system
observable. The second thing is open
telemetry. Open telemetry is a standard.
It is a recent addition and it provides
a whole ecosystem of tools and SDKs and
best practices and resources so that you
can properly instrument your
application. It does not matter what
language that you're using whether it is
NodeJS or Golang, Python does not
matter. The community has built enough
APIs, SDKs and tools for all the
languages, all the major languages and
it is an open standard even though we
are using a proprietary tool like uh New
Relic. We can definitely integrate an
open telemetry collector so that we can
have more control about how we are
instrumenting our requests, how we are
instrumenting our components. That is a
side note. If we take a look at one
function which is called create to-do.
It is a service which creates a new
to-do. And if you try to track down what
exactly are we doing with the whole
logging monitoring and observability
workflow in the first statement after
the function starts executing we are
taking out the transaction which we have
put inside a context. We have a
middleware which is called enhanced
tracing. And when this middleware is
first triggered during the life cycle of
a request, this is the first point of
contact. Here we create a new
transaction using we create a new
transaction using the new relic method
and we add some of the parameters like
the service name which we take from our
configuration. Then the environment
whether it is local or production the IP
address and the user agent the request
ID we fetch the request ID and the user
ID the user email tenant ID etc. All the
information that we need during our
logs, our traces, we add it inside this
transaction and then what we do, we add
this particular transaction into our
context. So that when the request
reaches the service method which is this
method, we already have a transaction
which we have saved inside our context.
We can use that transaction to proceed
further. What happens with this workflow
is a single request will have a trace
which will start from that middleware
where we are creating the transaction
then it will reach the validation layer
then it will reach the service layer and
all of this will be a single instance of
a trace and that's how we'll be able to
debug our issues. So in the first
statement we try to take out the
transaction from our context and this
statement basically means that when this
function returns we want to end this
transaction for this particular segment
which is the to-do create service. Then
since we service layer we want to add
two more attributes to this particular
transaction. The user ID and the title
of the to-do that the user has requested
for. Then comes our login. As we have
discussed before, we want to log every
single important event in our
application. That's why at this point we
are logging that we are performing an
operation which is called create to-do.
This is the title of that to-do and we
want to log this particular event. Same
way if a priority is passed in the
payload, the request payload that the
user has sent, we are adding this
attribute also to that transaction. It
is available in the trace and we are
also logging that. Then we are logging a
message which is of info level that we
are initiating the process of creating a
new to-do and here we are doing some
kind of validation with the children and
parent relation. Same way here at this
point we execute the database operation
which creates the to-do and if we face
any kind of error at this point we are
logging that error again with the level
of error we are adding this error to our
trace using this particular transaction
and we are also adding the attribute
that this operation create so that we
can know that for this operation the
result is an error but if it is
successful ful then we are adding that
the operation is create and we have
created a to-do with this particular ID.
We are also adding a log with the level
debug. We are printing logs with the
debug level that a to-do was created
successfully with this particular ID.
This will not be visible in our
production systems or our production
log. And finally we are logging another
important event which is a business
event log for the operation to-do is
created and all the associated metadata
with it. The ID of the to-do with the
title, the category ID and the priority.
And this is how a workflow looks like
with all the logging and observability.
And we'll see the monitoring part just a
bit in our New Relic dashboard. So going
back let me change it back to JSON so
that these logs are visible in our New
Relic dashboard and I have made the log
as JSON and change the value to
production for the server. Uh this is
the dashboard of New Relic and if we
click on our application these are some
of the data error rates that transaction
time etc etc. Since there was no
activity in the last 30 minutes, there
was no data to display here. But let's
trigger some requests here. Say for get
all to-dos. This is the open API
interface where we can test our APIs.
And if we let if we fire this API a
couple of times since we have not
provided any token, we are getting an
error of unauthorized. But we want to
check if this error gets logged in our
dashboard. trigger this a couple of
times. Then going back, go to errors in
our dashboard. Let's do a refresh here
and going to the HTTP error type. Now
here we can see that uh we have got a
couple of unauthorized errors and these
are the related logs as we have
discussed before in our whole logging,
monitoring and observability setup. All
these things work together so that we
have a complete understanding of our
system so that we can debug better. So
coming from our metrics, these things
are called metrics. If we go here, if we
go to the summary part, these are called
the metrics. What is the average
transaction time, the throughput, the
errors, these are the metrics, actual
numbers that we can see so that we can
quantify the state of our system. And
from the metrics, let's say from error,
it's around 80% average. From the
errors, we can find the logs. And if we
click on this log, the unauthorized
part, we can see all the information
that was associated with this log. This
is the name of our application. There's
the environment that was running on.
This is the error code who is
unauthorized, the host name, the IP, the
level of the error, the message, what is
the method, the get method, what is the
API route that we are trying to fetch,
which is the /todos part and the span
ID, the timestamp and everything related
to this log. This part is called a log.
And this is also connected to a trace.
As I said, we have three pillars. One is
logging, second is metrics and the third
one is traces. Now if we click on this,
this is the whole trace that we can look
more into and get more information from
here. Similarly, if we want to take a
look at our transactions in
transactions, we have in code uh at this
part we are talking about transaction
and we are adding more attributes.
transaction and the whole path of the
transaction that was getting tracked
here and we can track and we can see the
results of all those transaction from
this dashboard. So if we click on this
/todos we can get all these different
data for this particular transaction
different error rate the different
response time and all these different
data. Similarly, if we click on the go
runtime, we can get more information
about the system where our application
backend application is actually running.
This is the garbage collection time, the
memory uses which is just 3 MB, the
throughput and the average response time
and all these different things. So, this
is what I wanted to show in this video.
The whole discussion about logging,
monitoring and observability. This is
just a practice and we implement these
practices in a spectrum. We cannot say
that a system is completely observable.
It is logging and monitoring the 100% of
the parameters. But we implement this in
a spectrum and we have different
different tools to record and measure
them. If we are going with the open
source route, we have Graphana, we have
Loki, we have Prometheus, Jagger for the
traces. And if we are going with a
proprietary software so that our whole
setup is a little more simplified then
we have services like Newelic data dog
etc etc. And using these services
whether it is opensource or it is
proprietary we can get all these
different information about the state of
our service the state of our application
the state of our infrastructure
different interaction of different
different components and everything we
can imagine. Of course, we have to
actually implement that as we saw in our
code to have that result in the first
place. But assuming that we have done
everything from our part in the code
side, we'll have a complete
understanding, a complete dashboard view
in whatever software that we are using,
it does not matter. But this whole
workflow of logging, monitoring and
observability is a collective effort.
You as a developer have to do it on code
level and the infrastructure people the
devops people they also have to have the
correct setup so that they can collect
they can monitor all these metrics and
they can collect all these logs and
traces. So that's all there is to talk
about logging monitoring and
observability. There is not particularly
skill that you have to learn but you
have to keep in mind that this is a very
important part of any production